right now I feel like I'm on like a food
eating competition show it's a lot of
meat hey what's going on guys I'm Zack
and today I'm going to eat like an NFL
player I'm a Patriots fan but I'll watch
any football game an NFL player eats
probably a large amount of calories a
day to kind of fuel them through their
multiple workouts give me the food who
do we got
ah all right JJ Watt he is one of my
favorite players in the NFL so I'm
looking at Luke Kuechly diet he's a
linebacker so that's in this big meal
the Tom Brady diet restricts your intake
from the following foods I didn't pay
attention to any other word other than
Tom Brady
also more preparedness the Tom Brady
diet restricts your intake from the
following foods gluten-containing foods
caffeinated foods and drinks you
shouldn't drink coffee tea energy drinks
soft drinks and chocolate I already
don't drink caffeine so that's great
dairy containing foods non-organic non
local or non seasonal produce this diet
is seasonal foods containing added
sugars artificial sweeteners MSG or
trans fats should be avoided what am i
eating for breakfast
he has oatmeal with blueberries and
strawberries okay let's do a bowl six
eggs banana and an apple okay that's a
lot he has oatmeal made with slow-cooked
oats with a handful of protein enriched
granola mixed berries a big scoop of
peanut butter and some honey into the
dish to sweeten it just a tad okay
peanut butter and banana toast made from
whole wheat bread and the NFL linebacker
slices up some banana and adds it to the
peanut butter spread on the okay so I
like this technique breakfast homemade
granola stirred into coconut yogurt I'm
not supposed to have dairy containing
food so how am I supposed to have yogurt
is it coconut yogurt like coconut milk
yogurt because that would make sense
maybe I just talked myself into
understanding that it goes to his second
breakfast for his second breakfast he
has more eggs four to be precise two
slices of wheat toast with peanut butter
and banana and honey two slices of wheat
toast also with jelly all right so
I just left the grocery store my grocery
store doesn't necessarily have all the
things I want so I'm like fighting
myself going to multiple stores alright
so I forgot to buy my food last night so
I'm waking up really early this morning
to grab what I need because i'ma have to
have two of everything - breakfast is to
lunch - dinners it's now 10:30 and I've
got all my food to me about 93 dollars
pretty much is what JJ Watt eats per day
I mean it's just so much stuff and Tom
does this you know Tom and Giselle you
think they're at home and they're just
bacon away and don't think they are I
think they have a chef so I made the
steel cut oats took forever that's why
I'll mess with steel cut oats it's a
nice dough the consistency of this
coconut milk yogurt is not where it's at
good enough for you
Charlotte's people though it's real one
it looks pretty good almost on about
this eggs strawberries make breakfast
it's nice it's good we got steel-cut
oats and then we got whole wheat toast
with banana this is already so much and
I didn't even get to the toast so I just
got back from the gym I did like about
an hour hour and a half workout it's a
little bit more energized to be honest
but now I'm on my way back to my second
breakfast got the four eggs in there and
four pieces of toast again it's 1:30 so
this is gonna be a late late eating
festival the toast with the bananas and
almond and the honey was awesome for
lunch he has two pieces of grilled
chicken on whole-wheat toast with
lettuce and tomato and one whole sweet
potato and in between meals I work a
protein shake between meals and after he
puts in a big workout lunch raw lasagna
what the I can't have cheese again a
pasta that's what lasagna is made of
I'm making pesto for the first time this
is gonna be fascinating for lunch he
goes three chicken breasts with whole
wheat pasta and Italian dressing on the
side of broccoli again he's doubling up
on all his meals so his second lunch
he's gonna have more chicken breasts
with mashed sweet potatoes and steamed
carrots it doesn't say how many it just
says more this chickens gonna be roasted
and there's three here and it just says
more chicken breast so I'm just gonna
make one extra because I got to eat more
red meat after this all right
he goes you in oh did you get in here we
go lunchtime
we're gonna hit it off with the two
pieces of chicken okay so here we go
this big ol thing it's a mountain of
chicken but
I should be able to make it through
broccoli pasta and three chicken breasts
kicking the gun he's nice and moist
this is my Rolla Vanya how does it snow
it's good yes another smo but I made the
pesto it's not bad actually right now I
feel like I'm on that good food eating
competition show that's why prompt is
spot but just really that's a lot of
meat I've been thinking this for about
an hour I can't finish this I would just
like to know this is delicious
all right so I finished first lunch
plate is completely gone some chicken
fat there and when I go plow through
this second lunch right now I can't wait
to get back to normal schedule I just
think this nine thousand calorie thing
really works well if this is your only
job two more miles to go gonna finish
this one let's get it I just realized
that I ate a cupcake and a half without
even thinking about it
but they were like mini cupcakes but
also I'm not supposed to be eating
cupcakes on Tom Brady's diet she watched
me do it I did we shared one
I really did that without even thinking
dinner a big piece of salmon or steak
spinach salad with a handful of nuts and
mixed berries he also likes to add
seasoned veggies to keep a difference so
here it is dinner like even all the way
funky with y'all I'm genuinely still
full from watch and I'm probably only
gonna take a few bites of this and
dinner is lentil dal topped with fresh
spinach and served on a bed of brown
rice great I don't know what lentil dal
is I don't love lentils so great either
I'm just gonna say no to the final meal
that I'm supposed to do for this video
they gave me options of like things and
Tom Brady's meal plan and you want to
know what I'm going with for dinner
steak for dinner lamb chops and whole
wheat pasta with grilled asparagus that
sounds actually quite delicious if I
already didn't have four meals prior to
this and then of course a second dinner
a fillet with whole-wheat pasta
steamed broccoli so he does red meat for
dinner the one thing I'm disappointed
about this this whole diet is that
there's no first or second dessert -
lamb chops I'm supposed to do asparagus
but I just ended up using the carrots
they had from before that I made and the
holy pasta I'm feeling kind of full I'm
gonna cook through it I might do a
little bit of Himalayan pink salt on
here but sweet potato steak broccoli
this is my dinner this right here not
great it's just broccoli all right so I
finished the lamb and the whole wheat
pasta and my carrots which supposed to
be asparagus I'm just going to go right
to my second dinner look that's nice
pink you know overall this was uh this
was an experience
I prefer my own diet of just eating
whatever I'm hungry enough overeating
all this food tomorrow the story is will
I be doing Tom Brady's diet from now on
no was it interesting to follow it for a
day yes did I find a vegan recipe that I
actually enjoy yes I did I expected this
to be a lot easier than it actually was
I kept trying to push back dinner so
that you know I can digest some food
before I jump back into it and
that became an ordeal in itself because
I wasn't hungry even at 10:10 p.m. which
is when I cooked the dinner and ate it
so I took a few bites at the Salmons and
called it the hardest part was probably
finding everything and going to two
different grocery stores that are
significantly far away from each other a
lot of food and pretty expensive too
this is a $60 day I woke up this morning
not feeling like bloated or big or
anything like that but I did have to a
lot throughout the night I just don't
think it's it's feasible for someone who
is not an athlete who doesn't make
millions and millions of dollars a day
to actually cook all this stuff I mean I
spent the better half of the day cooking
everything and there you can say well
you can meal prep
good luck meal prepping on a Sunday when
you have to cook at least five chicken
breasts for one day's worth of food
[Music]